the crisis on our southern border
elicits a lot of reactions
a lot of emotions frustration
anger compassion all sorts of things
or if you are kamala harris maniacal
laughter
do you plan to visit the border
not today
but i have before and i'm sure i will
again
yeah visit the border
isn't it so funny isn't it so hilarious
i don't know to me the establishment
assault on our liberties
on our way of life on the american
nation itself
doesn't seem like a laughing matter i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from a.i
howard who says guess what michael
harry's lost a customer and you gained a
subscriber
so interesting that you would say that
it seems like
just another way of saying get woke go
broke i've gotten a lot of
emails from you so thank you for those
of you who have cc'd me on emails
too to harry's razors which
just appears not to want your business
if you are a conservative they don't
they don't really want your business
but some of the emails that you have
sent to to harry's and to us
have been very funny and we've seen
obviously thousands and thousands of
tweets on this point
probably not a great idea for companies
to
insult their customers not a great idea
at all you know i i've got great
memories
of uh of so many so many of those things
so many of the emails so
so i've got great memories that i want
to preserve
forever and when i want to preserve
memories i head on over to
legacy box legacy box is a way for you
to easily and affordably
digitally preserve your past the process
is extremely easy
from start to finish first you pack and
send your physical media
then their team digitizes everything by
hand then you enjoy it
they use premier scanners and playback
decks to ensure that each memory is
mastered to the highest quality
plus they keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
digitizing process
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
has helped over 850
000 families digitally preserve their
past including my family
you know i i unfortunately lost all the
photos that i had had
of a very beloved family member who had
died fortunately i then came in
through another relative to some more
photos sent them off to legacy box
now they are future proof forever get
started future proofing your memories
today so you can gather the family and
begin the trip down memory lane go to
legacy box dot com
knowles kennedy wles to get an
incredible 40 off your first order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send in when you're
ready
go to legacybox.com knowles and save 40
while supplies last the cackling is
kamala's
tell she's she's not a complex
politician she's a
actually a rather talented politician
she has
made it up the food chain up the
political ladder in ways that some might
consider to be a little bit unethical
but she really has done it she was the
first candidate that was booted out in
the 2020 democratic primary but somehow
she winds up being
vp to an elderly doesn't seem all that
well
president is a purely political matter
she's done well for herself
but she shares this this characteristic
this
tick actually with hillary clinton which
is that when she gets nervous
she starts to laugh you remember
remember hillary they said hey hillary
did you um
did you wipe your private email server
that had all sorts of nefarious stuff on
it
she goes what wipe like with a cloth
and it it isn't particularly attractive
when when people do that sort of thing
when kamala is laughing in this case she
is literally laughing at the reporter
she is laughing at the question but more
so she's laughing at us because the
reporter asks a very fair question hey
the biggest issue by far that that your
administration is facing right now
is this crisis that you have caused at
the southern border
that even mexico says you've caused that
the illegal aliens themselves have said
that you've caused
are you going to go down and visit and
gather some information you clearly
don't have enough information and try to
figure out how to deal with it
and she laughs she laughs because
of course she's not going to do that why
would she
it's a crisis for the migrants it's a
crisis for the american legal system
it's a crisis for the american people
but for the liberal establishment this
is
exactly what they want they want more
and more illegal aliens to come into
this country
because they think that it will give
them an electoral advantage and they
don't think that the united states
ought to have a right to national
sovereignty gen sakhi was just asked
about this our favorite current press
secretary
jensaki a peter ducey great great
reporter there
one of the few who's allowed into the
briefing room who's really tough
gen saki was asked if the illegal aliens
are being released
without the kovid tests often without a
court date even to reemerge
what are they are they just being
trusted with the honor system of
immigration she has no answer so now
that
border patrol agents in the rio grande
valley are
letting adult migrants go
without even issuing notices to appear
is the immigration policy just becoming
more of like the honor system
that is an inaccurate depiction of
what's happening
at the border so there's no change in
policy the border remains closed
uh families and single adults are being
expelled under title 42
and should not attempt to cross
illegally so if families are going to be
going to be deported and they're
awaiting deportation
they don't need a court date and they
don't need a notice to appear because it
has already been determined
that they will be sent back to their
home countries so
hold on hold on what you're telling me
now is that the biden administration is
being really really tough on illegal
immigration because
what we've just been hearing for the
past several days is that these illegal
aliens are being released
into the country without a court date
and without
any expectation that they're going to
show up again and leave the country
we're seeing record numbers of people at
the southern border now
and we're being told even by people on
the left that that number is expected to
swell even more
so are you you're telling me just don't
believe my
lying eyes don't believe the reports
that we're getting
from left-wing outlets even don't
believe
the the statements of biden
administration officials because
actually everything's totally hunky-dory
and the illegal aliens are not getting
in is that is that
right peter ducey presses the question
but if
secretary mayorka says the border is
secure the border is closed how is that
the case that these migrants are being
processed
on this side of the border and then put
on a bus
to points on unknown on this side of the
border
well again there are limited cases where
there are families because they can't be
held in mexico
who are uh who are processed tested
considered
at the border most of them are sent back
to their home countries those are very
limited cases and it's certainly not a
depiction of the overarching policy
so vague as that answer was it's it's
also
not true you you had people like the
secretary of the department of homeland
security who refuse to say that that
people are being tested
for the coronavirus 100 of the time when
they come in
so that that part just isn't true now
you're saying well there are some
limited cases where people are being
they make it to this side of the border
and they're being you know they're being
held in some facilities
at record numbers way over capacity and
some limited cases where they're being
shipped other parts of the country
in record numbers well those limited
cases don't seem very limited i mean
this is
as close to an outright lie just about
as it gets in politics
gensake is telling us to to
disbelieve what we can see with our own
two eyes this is a a policy of
gaslighting speaking of gaslighting
there is a terrible event occurred a
couple days ago we did we did not get to
it on the show yesterday
this was this terrible shooting in
colorado 10 people were killed
in a grocery store and a shooting in
boulder colorado after a man walked in
to king super's store and opened fire
and before you heard any details
about this shooting you saw
prominent left wingers tweeting posting
commenting
about the perils of white supremacy and
how this is
just more evidence that evil white
americans
need to i don't know have their
liberties curtailed or need to be
dealt with as a public health problem
and then then it turned out it was not
white supremacy the shooter's name
we have a policy at the daily wire where
we we do not say the shooter's name so i
won't say the full name
uh the first name is ahmad so
[Music]
you know use your mind from there it's
not like john smith
okay it's not it's not a name you would
associate with
uh say white supremacy uh actually this
this guy was a syrian immigrant
his family came here in 2002 he's not
christian we
we hear this talk about christian
nationalism now this is another
silly phrase that's being conflated with
white supremacy
uh he wasn't christian he's muslim so
now
we've gone from blaming the shooter
and everything he was going to represent
back when the liberals thought that
he was a white guy now we're talking
about the guns
and it's so it's so bigoted
it gets to something we talked about
yesterday we've talked about it several
times in the past few weeks
according to the left's racial ideology
only white people
are fully people according to the left
actually specifically only white men
only straight white men only straight
white men who know that they're men that
narrow group those are the only people
with
agency with will and with intellect
every other group of people is some sort
of
passive entity that that is merely a
victim of whiteness and white supremacy
so when they thought it was a white guy
oh well that's
his fault and and everything that he
represents when they find out he's not a
white guy
oh well we gotta ban guns
or some people actually persisted we we
played a clip yesterday on the show
where some millennial gal came out and
said that
even if a racial minority perpetrates a
crime against
another racial minority that can be
uh part and parcel of white supremacy
how
i don't know that's the premise that
they're that they're beginning with
now they're blaming the guns identity
politics actually
does have something to do with this
shooting
according to the denver post and
according to people who apparently knew
the guy
denver post very interesting article
said that
this guy hernandez who knew the shooter
said that the shooter apparently
appeared to be paranoid about perceived
slights
against him and another person who knew
the shooter
said that he was often concerned about
being targeted because of his
muslim faith so so one of these guys
says he would talk about him being
muslim and how if anybody tried anything
he would file a hate crime and say they
were making it up it was a crazy deal
i just know he was a pretty cool kid
until something made him mad and then
whatever made him mad
he went over the edge way too far so
according to people who who knew the
shooter
he the shooter recognized that grievance
was
social currency that the racial and
religious
identity politics that now pervades our
culture
could be used as a weapon could be used
as a political tool
and apparently he was rather taken with
this kind of grievance politics
the same sort of grievance politics that
had people jumping to the conclusion
based on nothing other than bigotry i
suppose or prejudice
that the shooter was a white guy but
then the minute he wasn't never mind
back to business as usual
back to our regular old identity
politics and we're supposed to pretend
that that never happened
it i think it is important to learn the
motivations of these
shootings very often they're just
completely senseless they're just some
lunatic
sometimes there is a kind of perverse
sense to them
and whenever there is a perverse sense
to these shootings
that the left thinks it can make get
some sort of advantage out of
say it was white supremacy or something
like that then they will harp on that
ad nauseam and is it actually
interesting
to try to figure it out to see what role
these ideologies play
but the minute and this is a more
frequent occurrence the minute that
the ideological underpinnings and
motivations for these crimes
in any way touch on what the left is
mainstreaming today
well then we got to forget about that
stop it we're not allowed to talk about
it we have to stay quiet
we got to talk about the guns
you know when you want to really really
get to the heart of a problem
it helps to have really good employees
which is why you got to check out the
zip recruiters if you're a business
owner who's hiring you probably face
a lot of challenges when it comes to
finding the right person for your role
that is why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack which is
why you got to try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com knowles k
w l e s when you post a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top job sites with one click
but it doesn't just stop there it's not
just like throwing spaghetti at the wall
zip recruiters matching technology then
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply it's
no wonder that over 2.3 million
businesses
have come to zip recruiter for their
hiring needs
so while other companies will overwhelm
you with way way too many options
ziprecruiter finds what you are looking
for that needle in the haystack
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at zipruder.com
knowles remember to go to this unique
url so they know we sent you
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
senator alex padilla who is a democrat
from california is uttering
a typical democratic party line you're
going to hear a lot more people
parroting
it for the next parroting it it's a
parody of itself but parroting this line
for the next several weeks which is that
in this country
it's easier to get a gun than it is to
vote
you know for most states the age
required to legally purchase a rifle
and the age required to cast a ballot
are both 18. however there's some
shocking disparities
in uh legal state requirements for
obtaining a weapon versus
casting a ballot in 25 states
voters must be registered and have
specific forms of id
in order to cast the ballot but those
same states allow people to buy rifles
without permits
and require no background checks for
some sales
additionally in the majority of states
new voters are
able to obtain a rifle quicker
than they are able to cast their first
ballot
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
than we do to cast the ballot so the
guy's wrong on the particulars but he's
wrong on the philosophy
and the constitutionality as well
the right to keep and bear arms the
right to defend yourself
is a more fundamental constitutional
right than the right to vote
you also have a right to vote not
everybody by the way people under 18 for
instance do not have a right to vote
thankfully thank goodness though
democrats are trying to change that
right now
some people depending on your state
felons for instance in some places do
not have the right to vote
totally up to the states to do that
the the right that is given to you and
that is
pardon me that is enshrined in the
second amendment
a right that our founding fathers
supposed us to have
inherited which is why the language says
shall not be infringed
that is a more basic constitutional
right however
the factual claim he's making here that
it's easier to get a gun
than it is to vote is simply not true
first of all
when he says it's easy it's quicker to
go buy a gun than it is to vote
i suppose that's true in the sense that
there's an election day so you know if
you
want to go buy a gun on a tuesday in
march
you can go do that unless you're in a
place like california then you have to
wait actually quite a while to get that
gun
but if you want to go vote on the
tuesday in march you probably have to
wait until november okay
fair enough but that's we have election
days for that sort of thing
and by the way the democrats are
extending election day into election
month so that seems to be changing
too the reason that the democrats are
pushing this argument
pseudo-argument now in particular is
because they're trying to push through
the corrupt politicians act this is the
name some republicans have given to
hr1 democrats top priority to
steal power over elections for
themselves
incumbents in congress trying to steal
the right to set all the election rules
from the states
and give it to themselves gee what could
go wrong when the
present office holders get to write all
the rules for their own elections
and what this would do is prohibit
states prohibit the people
from making their own election laws in
in many cases
prohibit voter id
in elections anywhere so not even just
saying that you don't need a voter id
but actually saying that in these
elections
it is not permissible for states to pass
laws requiring voter id
all based on some demagogic
ridiculous arguments about racism or
something now
if the democrats manage to do that it
will be very very difficult for
republicans to win elections which is
the entire point of it
there will be legal challenges because
it would appear to me quite clear that
the law is unconstitutional
but it doesn't really matter i don't
think because ultimately what that law
is going to come down to is the raw
exercise of political power and if the
democrats get it through they're going
to be able to exercise that power
and republicans frankly are too cowardly
to exercise
political power even when they're given
it but make no
mistake the arguments here for the
corrupt politicians act
the arguments about voting rights that
people like padilla are making
completely bogus basically what it boils
down to is that if you
have any restrictions on voting if you
have any voter
integrity measures for that matter that
that is somehow evidence of racism and
white supremacy
well there's a new poll out it's out
from hep
that shows that a majority of americans
including a majority of black and
hispanic voters
overwhelmingly support voter id which is
a
central election integrity measure so 77
of americans overall support
laws that require you to show an id
before you cast a ballot
that's compared to just 15 percent who
oppose the idea
92 percent of republicans support voter
id 75 percent of independents
support voter id 63 percent of democrats
according to this survey
support voter id but how about black and
hispanic voters because we're talking
about race right isn't this all about
white supremacy
well among black voters 64 support voter
id compared to just
22 who do not and 78 of hispanic voters
support voter id compared to 16 percent
who do not if we're actually talking
about
racial groups defending their rights or
how they're going to be able to interact
in our republic
voter id is a totally winning issue but
democrats
don't care what those voters think about
voter id because they know
that without voter id it will be much
much easier for them to steal elections
there are a ton of other measures in the
corrupt politicians act that will do
this too
automatic voter registration which they
know 100
guaranteed will result in the
registration of
millions of illegal illegal voters
many many other measures too we went
into it a little bit when when hr one
was proposed
and it it's actually quite plausible
that it makes it through the senate
because it looks like joe manchin
is going a little squishy he would have
been the the semi-moderate democrat to
say no to this
we'll go more into it in the future but
suffice it to say
the arguments they're making on white
supremacy
on guns on voting completely 100
without merit they're just
gaslighting us and they're gaslighting
the black and hispanic voters that
they're pretending to speak for
even our serial companies are
gaslighting us these days
yes our breakfast cereal companies are
gaslighting us
if you missed this yesterday you missed
the most enjoyable thing on the entire
internet
a guy with a blue check mark named
jensen carp
discovered shrimp tails in his cereal
in his cinnamon toast crunch and it's
gross and you can see the shrimp tails
are covered up
covered up in cinnamon sugar he tweets
out
um cinnamon toast crunch he tags them
why are there shrimp tails in my cereal
this is not a bit
cinnamon toast crunch responds and says
we're sorry to see what you found
we would like to report this to our
quality team and replace the box
can you please send us a dm to collect
more details thank you
they want to replace the box so this guy
jensen corp responds and says guys
i'm not sure i'm ready for another box i
don't finding like gross shrimp tails in
my cereal i don't
another box is the last thing i want
cinnamon toast crunch response says we
understand your concern
we promise you that our team will look
into this and get to the bottom of it
but in the meantime we want to do
everything we can to make this right we
need further details
then they come back and he keeps joking
with them they come back and say after
further examination with our team that
closely examined the image
it appears
tails there it is not physically
possible to make cinnamon sugar
look like these shrimp tails it is
there's no
there is cinnamon sugar on the shrimp
tails but it's just very clearly
shrimp tails so then this this guy
responds and says
okay uh well after further investigation
with my eyes
these are cinnamon-coated shrimp tails
you weirdos i wasn't all that mad until
you tried to gaslight me
then the cereal company offered him some
coupons for cereal and
the saga has been on pause there
this is not to go after cinnamon toast
crunch even for putting shellfish in
people's cereal
that's unfortunate but one suspects they
didn't do that intentionally
maybe some little rodent dragged them
into some cereal vat or something i
don't know
accidents happen uh it's a pretty gross
accident it's probably gonna
have me pausing on eating cinnamon toast
crunch for some time it's a good cereal
but the real issue here is the
gaslighting
we've actually been talking about this
for several days now
the late conservative loss for roger
scrutin he said civilization
requires confession and forgiveness i
need to be able to say when i've done
something wrong and you need to be able
to forgive me
and i need to sacrifice my pride and you
need to sacrifice your resentment
and we both sacrifice something that we
cherish and then we move on
in our present culture you might call it
a cancel culture
you can't ever admit that you're wrong i
actually have some sympathy here
for cinnamon toast crunch because there
is no forgiveness in our culture anymore
so the natural inclination here is to
say no that's not true it's not
whatever you're seeing it didn't happen
that is a culture of gaslighting where
we're not even allowed to acknowledge
basic truths
this is true in our politics more
broadly
if you say that a man is not a woman to
go back to this kind of most obvious
example
that is something that no one is allowed
to acknowledge in our culture anymore
we're not allowed to acknowledge basic
truths
because of of the implications they
might have we're all
so on the defensive we can't even call
the shrimp tails in our cereal
like we see them if you want to deepen
your
knowledge and wisdom and education
beyond this kind of silliness you got to
check out
the great courses they are fabulous with
the great courses plus
you have unlimited access to thousands
of video and audio courses
on hundreds of fascinating topics learn
a new language
discover what einstein got wrong even
gain valuable insights into your own
public persona
there really is something for everyone
here you know me i don't want to
learn about anything practical i want to
learn about for instance their their
great new course
1066 the year that changed everything
maybe maybe we'll talk about that the
battle of hastings bishop odo all these
great things
but really you can learn just about
anything you want i also find
when i'm sitting up with my cute little
screaming son in the middle of the night
it's kind of fun to throw on something
educational rather than just keep
burning my mind on the same
you know episodes of whatever the
courses are taught by the best
professors the top experts in their
fields plus with the great courses app
you're free to watch listen and learn on
any device at any time
switch between devices it's really
terrific i'm really glad that i found a
more productive way to spend my free
time
i want you to try the great courses plus
to get started with a free month of
unlimited access
by going to thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles that's a whole month to learn
anything you want for free so remember
to sign up right now at
dot thegreatcoursesplus.com slash
knowles k-w-l-e-s
also uh we're going to hear a lot more
about the left's lies on whiteness and
gun control in ben's show today
so head on over check out the bench
bureau show and also
most importantly of all you got to check
out the candace owens show coming up
this friday candace owens has a
brand new talk show it is exclusively
available
for daily wire members now candace is
also a podcast that you can listen to on
applespotify or anywhere else that you
get your podcasts
the candace podcast features a bunch of
breakout segments
from the full-length show including
interviews panel discussions
and her advice corner it's so good in
fact that it reached number two on the
apple podcast charts just after the
first episode
so head on over i am reliably informed
that candace is going to have a very
sophisticated intelligent extremely
handsome guest on her show this week
i won't say any more than that but it
should be a lot of fun so head on over
i'll leave a five-star review on the
podcast if you wouldn't mind
we'll be right back with a lot more
cinnamon toast crunch is gaslighting
customers over
shrimp tails in their cereal but
cinnamon toast crunch is not the only
sugary treat
in the news krispy kreme is in the news
right now
because as part of a broader effort to
encourage americans to get vaccinated
krispy kreme has announced that they
will be giving out one
free glazed donut every single day
to anyone who brings in their
vaccination card into any store
in the united states for the rest of the
year
this is the difference between the stick
and the carrot right this is the
difference
in incentives uh through punishment and
incentives through reward
the public health apparatus in this
country really really really wants you
to get this vaccination
not just if you're 85 years old or
you're greatly at risk
but even if you're you're a young
healthy person who
really doesn't need it and is not really
personally all that much at risk
they really want you to get the
vaccination now krispy kreme is going to
be offering people donuts every single
day for the whole year
if they do this i mentioned that you
know getting a vaccine makes sense if
you are 85 years old or something like
that
it also makes sense if you are extremely
overweight
because obesity is one of the strongest
predictors of vulnerability to
coronavirus
what what krispy kreme is doing here is
so such a perfect example
of what our public health apparatus has
done from the very beginning of this
virus which is to constantly
undermine its credibility and many many
public health measures
i i would understand if like the juice
company
or the health food company were offering
this to say come on in and you know
you'll get
you'll get a smoothie or something every
day if you have the vaccine
but it would seem counterproductive
during a pandemic
that disproportionately affects
overweight people
to give them donuts every single day to
try to stop
the pandemic a classic example of of
our benevolent bettors out there are
experts or geniuses
totally botching the response also
i like to think that i'm i'm a little
more expensive than a donut
you know if you're trying to get me to
do something that maybe i'll do maybe i
won't maybe i'm a little reluctant to do
it
i like to think that i can i have a
higher price i can't be bought off
for one glazed doughnut no matter how
delicious it is
there's that old old line an old joke
about a guy who
walks up to a woman and says hey i want
to want to pick you up for the night you
know treats her like she's a prostitute
and i'll give you a hundred dollars if
you go back and sleep with me she slaps
him across the face
and says how dare you that's outrageous
and he says okay how about a million
dollars
then she thinks about it she says well
okay well million dollars maybe i'll
i'll think about that
he goes okay how about 200. she slaps
him again
how dare you you said a million dollars
and he says look i was just trying to
figure out what you are now we're just
haggling over the price
i i think that i would like to be bought
for a little bit more
than a krispy kreme doughnut and i i
think that if we're going to have public
health measures
they should probably be coherent they
should probably
make sense speaking of things that
people eat when they are very high
lest i never be accused of giving joe
biden credit for it for anything
i have to report on this very
underreported story from the new york
times
joe biden is firing potheads
yes joe biden is
tossing out five people who used
marijuana in the past
which we'll call now into question his
new guidelines that say that if you
smoke pot it doesn't really matter you
can work in the white house
i'm not saying this because i have some
personal grudge against pot or because
i've never
never puffed on the devil's lettuce in
my life or anything like that
but i don't think that we should further
legalize that sin spinach you know that
jamaican oregano
i don't think that it's some matter of
profound
constitutional natural rights even that
you should be able to uh
to puff on a blunt or anything like that
it's like it's not the worst thing in
the world but it isn't good and and
unlike say alcohol or other intoxicants
that are
much more natural to our culture much
more traditional rather in our culture
marijuana is relatively new to the
culture and i just don't see any reason
to
introduce it also i noticed that most of
the people clamoring to legalize
marijuana like their life depended on it
are big libs and i just i don't see any
reason to uh to suspect that they're
right about that
my my gut just tells me that's wrong
also
it is still the law right i mean there
are now contradictory laws at the local
level the state level
and the national level on on the gange
you know so
i think we need to get those laws in
order we need to sort this sort of thing
out and i actually get a real kick that
joe biden is taking this issue seriously
don't forget just 20 years ago
you could really not admit that you'd
smoked pot when bill clinton
in the 90s was was asked about whether
or not he'd smoked pot he had to come up
with this ridiculous totally clintonian
obviously dishonest answer he said
i smoked it but i did not inhale i
know i just kind of molded around in my
mouth and then i
puffed it out like a cigar speaking of
cigars
well never mind we'll get to that later
and
now of course if you don't smoke pot
you'll be like a square you probably
couldn't be elected if you say
that you've never smoked pot that is a
seemingly trivial cultural change but
it shows it shows the development of
what what you might call the permissive
society
this is a phrase used by the historian
paul johnson among other people
this idea that we should be allowed to
do whatever we want
at least as long as it doesn't harm
anybody and for a while
it was really just leftists who were
pushing this idea then for some reason
over the past
10 20 years conservatives have started
to buy into this idea too
but it's ridiculous it actually gets
gets into the heart of something
we're talking about a lot these days
which is political correctness how it
advances
this is the subject of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available now for pre-order until it
gets cancelled
these debates over i don't know drug
policy or
over speech even it's not a debate
between freedom
and censorship right all speech regimes
all drug regimes all
all these sorts of policies are finite
things where you can do some things and
you can't do others
the question is really over standards
what are we going to support what are we
going to
discourage what are we going to include
what are we going to exclude
and i i got to tell you i got to give
biden a little bit of credit
he's drawing kind of a strange line in
the sand for someone who's now
importing illegal aliens into the
country in record numbers but
nevertheless he is drawing a little bit
of a line in the sand and a good on him
for it
it gets into this question even of of
say academic freedom
there's an organization right now the
academic freedom alliance
which is supporting some right-wing
professors some
i guess some left-wing scholars are
involved in this too
but they've come to the defense of tom
smith who is a professor who is now
under investigation for a blog post in
which he criticized the chinese
government
and a lot of conservatives are upset
about this and even this organization
that specifically supports academic
freedom is going after it too
wonderful we should welcome their
support that's great so glad that
they're
supporting professors who criticize
china however
academic freedom is not a conservative
virtue it's not not a conservative value
actually the modern conservative
movement founded by bill buckley was
started with a book called god and man
at yale the subtitle of which was
the superstitions of academic freedom a
book in which buckley called academic
freedom
a hoax because it is a hoax it's just
it is a dishonest instrument that is
used almost exclusively by the left
to push their ridiculous and subversive
and
and dangerous and uh what other words
can i use destructive ideas into
universities
we all know this and conservatives i
don't think we actually support academic
freedom i think we want to kick
all the crazy radical anti-american
professors out of the universities i
think we want to kick them out of
hollywood i think when we say
we need to take back the culture what we
are saying quite obviously is
we want to exclude certain views certain
certain curricula but then we feel
uncomfortable with that and so we say
but we support academic freedom no you
don't be honest with yourself
i don't i don't support it either one
because it doesn't ever really exist
curricula are finite things the semester
is only so long
you're going to teach some things you're
not going to teach other things you're
going to include some books you're going
to exclude other books
so this academic freedom pie in the sky
abstract notion
doesn't really have much practical
effect what we have to get down
to defending as conservatives is not
just the abstract
procedures of politics you know free
speech in the abstract
religious liberty and the abstract
academic freedom in the abstract we have
to get down to what
we actually want to say what we actually
believe
what we actually think ought to be
taught i don't think any conservative
who supports academic freedom
thinks that universities should be
holding classes promoting the 1619
project
which is based on a lie i don't know
nobody would support that of course not
we should exclude lies from the
university
and we should include good edifying
truthful
education the the the issue here with
this professor who's under investigation
is not that his academic freedom has
been compromised
if he had written blog posts talking
about how evil the country is and how he
wants to overthrow the american way of
life
i wouldn't defend him the issue here is
that he's talking about
china he's criticizing china and he's
being punished
for criticizing china by the way if the
guy wrote his blog
posts criticizing america he'd probably
be promoted he'd probably be the dean of
his department by now
but because he was criticizing china now
he's he's under fire
that's the problem the the i think
underlying premise to all these really
abstract arguments
is that we really can't differentiate
between right and wrong between good and
bad between china and america we can't
between drag queen story hour and going
to church on sunday we just can't
differentiate and so every we have to
support
all of these things and we have to have
no standards at all give me a break if
you
can't rely on your moral conscience to
make the most basic judgments of reason
between good and bad and right and wrong
and true and false
then you can't have self-government the
whole premise of self-government is that
we
consider these ideas we we distinguish
between
good and bad and right and wrong we make
judgments and then we
enact those judgments in our politics
that's the point of self-government
if you say that we can't do that anymore
for whatever reason
because you have a skeptical view of
knowledge or of conscience or whatever
then you can't govern yourselves and
increasingly it would appear that we're
not able to do that speaking of
self-government and speaking of
exclusion
there is a movement underway to make
washington dc
the federal district to turn it into a
state
the left has been pushing this for a
while it's completely incoherent and now
they're going after
one expert on this zach smith who is
testifying about some of the reasons
against dc statehood and they're saying
he's making ridiculous frivolous
arguments
take a listen to his argument framers
also wanted to avoid
one state having undue influence over
the federal government
there's no question that d.c residents
already impact the national debate
for the members here today how many of
you saw dc statehood yard signs or
bumper stickers or banners
on your way to this hearing today i
certainly did
where else in the nation could some such
simple actions
reach so many members of congress so the
left went after this guy
zach smith and said this is ridiculous
he
he wants to claim that dc has
special representation because what
lawmakers look at yard signs give me a
break
well that's true lawmakers spend
a lot of time in washington dc and
the things that happen in washington d.c
disproportionately affect the national
conversation that's just
obvious that's just common sense i was
in dc two days ago
and this is why we refer to the swamp
right this is why we refer to the dc
bubble
is because the people are there living
in a particular place and they're having
the the conversations and debates that
will affect our national politics
and the point he made at the very top of
that is true too the founders
did not want any particular state to
dominate all the other states
that is specifically why they said no
it's not going to be maryland
that has the nation's capital it's not
going to be virginia
it's going to be this kind of area that
we carve out from these places
and it's going to be a federal district
there is
no argument not one single argument
for dc statehood
other than inclusion and this is
this silly slogan this bumper sticker
that the left is really pushing
that unfortunately a lot of people on
the right have fallen
for the trap of of parroting where
they'll say well come on let people in
dc they deserve a vote
well they vote on certain things but the
federal district is a very
special specific place if the d.c
residents
want to live in a place that's governed
under
different rules then they can move to
maryland or they can move to virginia
but if you're in dc you got to play by
the rules of dc
we actually need to exclude
washington dc from statehood
if you want to preserve the integrity of
statehood it's a great line from
chesterton
he says there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped
the inclusion of all the states in the
federal government in the united states
of america
relies to some degree on the exclusion
of washington d.c
because if washington dc remains a
federal district and not a state
then all the other states have
equal dominance over the nation's
capital namely
none of them have any dominance over the
nation's capital if washington dc
becomes a state
now we have true truly a hierarchy of
states
in the matter of law making in the
matter of the federal government
cannot cannot do it but something tells
me
that the inclusion argument is going to
continue
to persuade people who are not not
thinking very clearly
what the left is doing with inclusion is
trying to turn this into a race
issue so you're saying well you know a
lot of a lot of black people live in dc
so if you want to exclude it from
statehood it's because you're a white
supremacist
you know and they'll just continue to
use this phrase white supremacy as long
as it's in any way plausible i remember
this when
david webb the the political commentator
was interviewing a leftist on the radio
and she accused david webb of of
only holding his views and having
certain certain benefits because of his
white privilege
and david webb said ma'am i think if you
knew me better
uh you would not accuse me of that she
said no you do you've got white
privilege and
he said uh ma'am i'm i'm a black guy
i'm i'm like it's not even like that
ambiguous i'm pretty clearly a black guy
and she said oh yeah okay all right
never mind and then she moved on but
it's just the sort of line that you
throw at people
uh without any evidence you don't need
any evidence
tammy duckworth democrat is taking this
racial politics
even further she
has now said that she will not vote
for any biden nominee who is
a white guy a straight white guy tammy
duckworth says quote
i am a no vote on the floor on all
non-diversity nominees
you know i will not vote for racial
or rather i will vote for racial
minorities and i will vote for lgbtq
but anybody else i'm not voting for
this of course rank bigotry
it you know it's become cliche i almost
don't even want to say it if the
situation were reversed
you know this person would be cast into
outer darkness where they were wailing
where there was wailing and gnashing of
teeth in as much as there is any sort of
white identitarian
movement cropping up on the fringes of
our political discourse and i suppose
there's always
something like that on the fringes but
in as much as it's cropping up anymore
it's because of tammy duckworth that's
why
tammy duckworth and her fellow travelers
are the only people to blame for this
sort of thing
because i think if you polled all the
white people in america
and you said hey do you want to have a
politics based on racial identity
primarily
i think overwhelmingly the white people
would say no
no way but if
the left forces a politics of racial
identity
then there is no choice right this is
the problem with war and it's a problem
with politics
is your opponent your enemy gets a say
so if tammy duckworth is saying yeah
we're going to have a politics primarily
exclusively perhaps of racial identity
then you're going to create the the
phantom problem that you're pretending
exists right now the white
nationalist white identitarian a
total contrivance a total creation
of the left speaking of racial identity
politics have to get to this today
the first u.s city ever has approved
slavery reparations to black people not
the first u.s city that was ever created
but the first u.s city to approve
reparations for slavery
has just voted on evanston city council
voted eight to one monday night
to approve the first phase of
reparations allocating four hundred
thousand dollars
to be paid out in home ownership and
improvement grants up to 25 grand
the housing assistance is the first part
of a 10 million dollar plan for
reparations
to be paid to black people the black
people will have to prove that their
ancestors lived in the city between 1919
and 1969 when discriminatory policies
were in effect
applicants must also be able to trace
their lineage back to any of the black
racial and ethnic groups of africa
how are people going to do that they're
going to spit in a
swab you know they're going to take one
of these dna tests and prove it how
what happens if the documents are not
particularly
strong what if they're not reliable what
if they're being forged what if there's
corruption that creeps in
what if the politicians who were just
doling out money willy-nilly to people
based on
how dark their skin is what if they get
a little bit crooked about it
what if this is just the beginning what
if this is the beginning of a politics
primarily of racial identity
in the modern political era in this
country
certainly would seem that way i don't
think this is the end i think other
cities are going to vote on this too
and i think that a lot of conservatives
the squishy ones are going to go along
with it and they'll say well
you know i just don't want to be called
a racist and hey and you know what
they'll do the only argument they'll
make is
maybe we should have reparations for
other groups you know
anyone who's ever suffered any kind of
grievance or discrimination why is this
why is this one grievance
horrible though it was why is that the
only grievance that anyone is allowed to
claim
some justice for why
why not if you were if you're a
japanese-american and your parents were
interned
or your grandparents were interned
during world war ii
are you not entitled to some reparations
for that
what if you're an italian-american you
were treated you were treated in
parts of the south just like black
people were treated largest mass
lynching in american history was against
italian americans where's my money
where give me those reparations what if
you're an irish american you had
signs on the windows that say irish need
not apply to jobs where are your
reparations
what i could see i don't think any
republicans very very few prominent
republicans
are going to have the spine to say no no
reparations you don't get it i don't
i just don't want to hear about
horrible historic grievances not because
i deny that they existed
but because everyone can claim grievance
because this is a fallen world and some
people certainly can claim it worse than
others
but the way to have a country moving
forward is not to go back and relitigate
things that happened 200
300 years ago and to try to extort money
out of people through corrupt
government programs the way to move
forward as a country is confession and
forgiveness
a little bit of grace and love of your
country as an extension of your family
and your community
that's that's going to be the way
forward right before we go i have to
mention this article it's in cnn
speaking of people's physical
characteristics to shave or not to shave
how beards may affect covid19 health the
idea that
if you have a beard your mask might not
be as
effective and therefore you need to
shave all i have to say
on this particular story is
nice try harry's nice try
you know i know you've got it you're
facing a very difficult
news cycle right now because you
insulted hundreds of millions of
conservative americans and you said that
you don't want their business and now
they're they're canceling your product
by the thousands because you know i'm
seeing the emails and the tweets
nice try harry's pr team i'm not buying
this covid19 stuff okay
sorry sorry pal i think people can grow
beards
absolutely if they want to uh the the
credibility of
not just corporate america but of a lot
of our egghead bureaucrats
very much in question right now because
they've been gaslighting us
more and more each day i'm michael nolis
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show